tal como se puede observar en la unidad
educativa de alto irpavi de la ciudad de
la paz la votación en bolivia transcurre
con normalidad durante esta jornada
cuatro de las nueve regiones del país
eligen gobernador en segunda vuelta
electoral las regiones que están en
disputas son la paz chuquisaca tarija y
pando en todas ellas el movimiento al
socialismo es decir el partido del
oficialismo disputa el poder con
candidatos locales de la oposición la
jornada ha empezado a las 8 de la mañana
el presidente del tribunal supremo
electoral ha recordado que el voto en
bolivia es obligatorio y además ha
pedido canalizar a través de la
institucionalidad todas las diferencias
del país
esta elección es particularmente
importante para el movimiento al
socialismo que es el partido de luís
arce y de evo morales por que calibrarán
su poder en las regiones luego de haber
ganado con amplia mayoría en las
elecciones nacionales las mesas
electorales estarán abiertas durante
nueve horas al cabo de las cuales
empezará el conteo de votos
el tribunal electoral tiene siete días
para darlos
resultados sin embargo el presidente de
esta entidad ha señalado que se
procederá al conteo de la manera más
rápida posible